happy welcome you back for our uh last
of the three series uh afternoon talks
um Vincent Smit inan Naka will be
presenting their project over
investigating user needs and the true
reason why people read news take it away
yes uh thank you very much yes we are
going to talk about revealing the true
motives of Newsreaders um well at DPG
media uh we already did of course the
short introduction um let's just skip to
uh uh what is DPG media um it's a
Publishing Company originated in Belgium
and now also has a pretty pretty big big
market share in the Netherlands and we
offer a lot of different brands
newspapers magazines but also a lot of
online Brands and so we gather a lot of
data of course user data but also a lot
of content it's kind of the foundation
of the build of the of the
Enterprise and when you think about
content you might think about
personalization and when we think about
personalization we think about what is
the best content we we can offer to a
user what is the best experience and
what do they actually need from us need
from the news so that is what we are
going to talk about today uh we're going
to focus be focusing on user needs and
how we can predict user needs based on
the text of an article and we're going
to walk you through our whole process
from the start to uh the labeling
fine-tuning and also some results and
next steps
but first of all uh why are the user
needs actually important um and well we
didn't think of them thought of them
ourselves uh the BBC did a very big
investigation and they uh came up with
these six user needs uh because
apparently these were the needs uh the
main uh characteristics that people were
actually actually looking for when they
are reading the news so that's quite
interesting but they also found out that
it is quite important to have an equally
balanced uh to to equally balance your
content across these user needs to have
more satisfied more loyal and more
engaged customers and just also to get
more clicks so that's a very interesting
Insight because they also found out that
within most media companies that is not
at all the case and also within DPG
media the user needs are quite skewed a
lot of the news is just update me give
me the information but that is not what
a lot of people a lot of readers are
actually looking
for so um we are now using user needs in
two ways you can of course use it in an
editorial way because when you see how a
divert me article is written you
actually know um how to write also other
articles and you can actually write
about a topic and write uh about that
topic in many different ways to address
many different user needs so that's an
interesting Insight but furthermore of
course just for marketing
personalization when you see for example
those five articles you can easily
distinguish what the dominant user need
is and when you know the dominant user
need you can of course use it for
bannering for newsletters and we already
did uh a test with personalized
bannering and we actually saw when we
added the user needs to the banners we
got a improved clickthrough rate of
13.5% so quite some decent
results uh but we didn't actually just
use the user needs from the uh BBC we
changed them a little bit in order to
make them fit a little better to DPG and
we also Define them a little bit better
in order to make a better fit uh with
our company and we actually also
combined the last two the touch me and
the connect me but that was also just a
data issue because we didn't have that
much articles relating to that user need
so it was more easy to classify it by
just combining the two so we are
actually using five user
needs now let's talk a little bit about
the labeling process uh because at first
we have a lot of data but we have no
labels so we just started with a couple
of thousand of randomly selected
articles we had three labelers and we
just started labeling and the Articles
were from the three biggest Dutch
newspaper
titles uh we trained a bird model and
within that Bird model as you probably
know you can only uh analyze the first
512 tokens so we Temple to sample the
article text because a lot of the
articles are a lot longer than that and
we just took the beginning and the end
and a little bit of the middle and well
as you can see the first results were
actually quite good overall accuracy
almost 80% and all user needs
individually also scored pretty
well but the problem was um within the
first iteration well wasn't really
including in that phase but we only had
of course label data from the Dutch news
but we also have Belgium articles we
also have magazine articles and do they
actually are represented in the training
well probably not but we still scored
all the Articles so also the also the
magazine so in the next iteration we
thought all right we also need to
include those titles those magazines
those newspapers so we did another uh
another round and we actually labeled
another 4,000 articles but now we did it
with 18 labelers so we got a lot of
people from the company and we gave them
some training and we were really happy
because we thought all right this goes a
lot faster than with three labelers so
we actually trained it in the similar
manner but as you can see the results
after quite some months of work were
pretty bad and what we concluded all
right you can get a lot of labelers but
if they are not consistent if they are
not trained well and we thought we
really focused on that but but still we
didn't and believe me we tried a lot of
different ways but the result kept on
being um quite sad so well we eventually
needed to uh conclude that it was kind
of a waste of time but still of course
we learned a lot about the process and
the last phase uh that is the phase
we're actually looking uh working with
right now it's we reduced the 18
labelers Again to three we still are
using um articles over all the titles
that we have but we are now not just
focusing on random articles but we are
focusing on articles where the model
that we already have has difficulty
predicting because we already have
scores and a lot of the articles are of
course pretty easy for the model to
predict but there are also a lot of
Articles who are where the Max Pro the
max probability is quite low and that is
interesting of course for labelers to
look at and to see all right can we
improve the model with those articles so
so um we took 500 articles like that and
we also adjusted um the sampling of the
Articles because we talked with our
editorial manager and he said every
article has an introduction but the
introduction apparently in every article
is kind of the same so even if you are
have a connect me article the the intro
is quite just giving the facts like it's
in an update me article so he says just
remove it from every article because the
rest of the article that is where the
interesting information is in and it's
probably a lot easier for the model to
recognize the user need without that
intro and he says like that the end of
the article is also not important just
so just focus on the beginning without
the intro and that will probably
probably work best so we just gave it uh
gave the article like that um to the
model focused on the first 512 tokens
and that is also in the labeling process
where we looked at we only looked looked
in the labeling uh at the first 512
tokens and the results were actually
quite uh quite good uh because the
overall accuracy increase uh was a
little better than the first model but
as I mentioned it is only uh based on
the more difficult articles and the
first water model was focusing on all
the Articles so we were quite happy uh
with just those 500 uh labeled articles
that we got similar results as the first
model and well what we actually did is
just set up a whole Active Learning flow
a pipeline um and now we are actually
scoring every day all our articles and
so that we know which are the difficult
articles and we build up a data set and
all our labelers are a are able with our
uh own web application just to select
their own label set they can do that by
their themselves and they can just start
labeling and when we have enough train
data we actually retrain the model again
and again just to see if the model
improves and if the model improves we
just replace the old model with the new
model so it's a continuous process we
are currently working with in
production and of course continuous
monitoring is very important um so all
of the labelers are able to look at the
results themselves and see if the
labeling efforts actually paid off so
that's a little bit about that now
yurian is going to talk a little bit
more about the find thank you um yeah as
Vincent said that's mostly the process
we're in but we're also on the Pata
conference so we want to go a bit deeper
into what we technically did so this
part is more about for all the different
models that we estimated so the version
one but also the later versions what
steps did we take to train such a model
to train a model that is able to predict
what category an article belongs to what
user need it belongs to and it it has
five steps you could say so first I'm
going to tell a bit about the the setup
what did we use what kind of technique
did we use what kind of packages did we
use then I'm going to talk a bit about
the data we have available we have
article data actually we use it in two
ways I'm going to talk about that then a
post trainining of an LM and going into
detail there uh and we did a two step
for the user need for the last one so
for the user need prediction we first
did a hyperparameter search and for the
second part we did a fine-tuning with
some more uh a grid search so just to
give you some more insights in uh under
the hoood what we did to predict the
user meets so first of all what did we
use maybe you saw in the flow of Vincent
that there was a lot of data EQ icons
there for those who know dat EQ actually
we work in De Mo mostly in in in dat EQ
for for most of our things but we
switched here to data bricks because it
was for us as as data scientist was most
easy to dare get a GPU cluster that fit
fit our needs so we don't want to wait
too long we also don't want to spend too
much money uh so we want to do that in a
in in a responsible way to be able to
tune it tune it up tune it back so we uh
we use the we use data bricks we use a
number of python packages maybe some are
known to you others are not so we mainly
build on hugging phase uh they're they
great work so the Transformers uh um
package and the data sets package all
the data that we have we put it in data
sets dictionaries um that's it's really
a convenient way to to work with it we
have to SW switch uh we have to to go to
RVs and back so we we used some package
for there under the hood their storage s
they learn mainly to look at the
measures and to have some custom metrics
we want to evaluate on as Vincent
already said it's not only the overall
accuracy but it's also specific accuracy
so we use it for that optuna for the
hyper parameter search and ml flow to
register all our models and to be able
to go back to the best one we found and
to be able to also uh yeah explain what
the best model is so these are this is
the tra tring setup we used then about
the Articles because as Vin already said
de media a lot of Brands I think more
than 50 now uh all publishing articles
that means that we have a lot of data
available and we want to use llms um and
we can use them um but we've also post
trained those llms a bit to make those
more applicable to De use cases one is
use user needs but others are sentiment
of headers other models so we have made
our own LM that is more accustomed to De
data and we can use it so that's why we
could use actually not only the labeled
articles Vince already told it's quite a
hassle to get good labels so but for the
um for the first part we could use all
articles I'm going to discuss in a in a
bit how we use those and we have the
labels the articles that that Vincent
already talked about so about 11,000 in
total those are by hand by labelers
labeled for the user needs an important
thing is that we split the data into
this the different slices so we can
easily evaluate how good is this model
in general but also how good is it for
Belgium for the Flemish language and for
the Dutch language because there is a
difference those of you who are Flemish
will say yes it's really different so
there are different words used to
different uh uh text but also different
constructs there so we had to check if
the model that we are training now is
actually better and doing better for for
that and also news and magazin so
different kind of uh kind of content so
we have to evaluate on that if we're
doing better so that's that's good and
we combined them in the uh the data set
dictionaries uh that are part of the
hugging face data sets so that and in
the end yeah well if you work with
Transformer models you know you cannot
just put in the text you have to
tokenize it you have to translate the
words to tokens that the model knows
where it's trained on so that's also
part of the of the preparing the data
that we translated the text that we have
the tokens and those tokens can be used
in our Transformer model uh
training so that's phase
two um then the fine tuning so as I said
actually we have two parts in our
training and we called this one to
prevent a bit of uh misunder
understanding a posttraining so actually
we use a pre-train model that's a robot
2022 model that's Dutch it's trained on
Dutch data a lot of Dutch data also a
bit on newspaper data so you could say
that's already in there but it's also
trained on uh so social media data other
data all Dutch data available um and and
it's quite good it it outperforms the
model that we used earlier was the B
model and this was already quite better
also because it's more recent so it's
postco so the first model we used didn't
have any context of of coid and it's
obviously in the news quite important
last few years um so we used that one as
a starting point but we F WE Post
trained it on those 580,000 articles we
have from De to have it more accustom to
to the news articles that we have so in
that case it's it's it's better suited
not only for the user needs but we have
quite some labels but also for other
questions that we have and we could do
few shot learning with this model and
that's why we use this model as a
starting point also for the fine-tuning
here because yeah we can use all those
models because actually there we perform
the mass language modeling task there
the model says well I'm just going to uh
mask about 15% of all uh of all tokens
and predict what was the token or the
word that was there so the model doesn't
have to have label data it has its own
label data so that's all the that's the
thing about these these models that they
can be trained without label data so we
now have after this phase we have a
model that is actually the robot 22 but
it's the D robot 22 you could say so
it's customed to our own
data and with that as a starting point
we can look at how we can use it to
predict user needs so here we used also
as a first step we used optuna that's
another package you can use to do some
hyperparameter search and it's good
because you have still have quite some
hyperparameters you have to optimize if
you have this such a Transformer model
and this resulted for us into a good
starting point where still to do some
richar afterward but we have a better
starting point for some important hyper
parameters like the learning rate weight
Decay the train APO we want to do and
and some others so these are important
uh parameters you want to to tune and to
see what are the best optimal values for
for the context I have and it depends on
the data depends on your question you
have what the optimal uh values are so
it's it's good to have a good starting
point there not to lose too much time uh
so we we we we did that and that
resulted for us into a good set of
starting point uh
parameters um but then we still wanted
to do a grid search over some uh other
parameters so still the aox and the B
size and the learning rate we still
wanted to vary around the optimal value
to see what really is the best thing
also looking at the different slices we
wanted to look at so not the overall
performance only but also for Belgium
versus Netherlands also for magazine
versus uh uh
news um and we also tried to maybe
oversample the smaller uh categories to
see if that works so that was also one
of the things in in our grid search and
even multimodal to see okay maybe we
know some other information about the
articles that might help in predicting
the user needs so what is the author
what is the category it's placed on on
the website other things in the end
actually we saw that uh Transformer
model is quite capable of of of of
collecting that so it doesn't need this
extra information so most most of the
things we added were not valuable and in
the end we we could skip them but we did
test if it would help to to add those
and as I said a few slides ago it's
important for us to look at the metrics
that count for us so there not one
number or one uh best uh F1 or one best
Precision we really have to see if we're
able for the different slices in our
articles Dutch Netherlands magazine uh
uh Dutch Belgium magazine uh and news if
it's performing well on all the user
needs so we don't want a model that's
really under really really
underperforming for one user need we
know that some us are quite difficult to
to to to grasp because they're quite
related to other ones um and we don't
have a lot of training data on it but
still we want to do it as good as we can
so that's that's important so we had to
write some some custom metrics for that
um and actually all the evaluations we
did resulted in insights in the best
hyperparameters but also as Vincent
already told also in some Upstream
things so we had to go back and say well
we're tried a lot of things but we're
seeing that we're not improving H so we
for instance the interat reliability it
was quite low so we had to make the
decision to say well if if the same
article by two different raters is is
dead one says it's a user need one and
the other says user need two the model
cannot figure that out so we have to
have to have good data so we learned a
lot on there also about the quality of
the data and we sometimes unfortunately
we had to go back reduce the number of
labelers and also the process of of
labeling we had extra checks if we had a
discussion about it we had to together
have had to look at it so that that was
really important we had a lot of
learnings there in the end we evaluated
on these kind of uh stats m mostly I
won't go into into all details there we
wanted to see if we would improve
overall and to see that all the
categories would get better these these
numbers are quite low because here we're
zooming in in those most difficult cases
as Vincent already said in our Active
Learning setup we only label those
articles that are really difficult for
the model we added 20% to also have a r
Rand sample of all articles but most of
those articles are quite difficult for
the model so that's why the overall
scores are not that high but we do see
that our new model really improves on
the the
performance so we learned a lot uh
actually in in in in the process and
mainly not only about the model and how
to tune that but also about how to GA
the data and how to instruct laborers we
spent a lot of time instructing the
labelers but we saw we really have to be
in good control and it's also very very
important to keep on monitoring if uh if
the model performs well so that's what
Vincent already showed we have this
Active Learning setup where we
constantly monitor if the model is is is
getting worse and then we know that we
have to label new uh articles and those
are automatically used to update the
model and if the model improves that one
goes to production so that's that's the
loop we saw we also saw that we have to
keep it simple and it sounds quite
obvious maybe but it's quite tempting to
say well let people not say one user
article but let's give a distribution of
probability for us but it's a really
complex task to ask a labeler oh give it
80% to us KN one and 20% to us KN b or
let them score it or rate it on a
paragraph level that increases the
amount of tasks they have to do
enormously so all those things we always
have to check are we over compli fying
things so no let's not do that and we
saw in in the end that we could improve
without those things so that's good as a
last
Point yeah yeah as a last point it's
um uh what we're working on now we want
actually want to the model is now
production each article that is
published is immediately scored with our
model you get the Marx user need and you
get the probability per user need but we
want to have it earlier in the process
when someone's writing an article
actually has to see what what the user
need is that he's writing so he can
still change the article so now we're in
a process to get actually our model in
the content planner and that's actually
the environment where someone writes the
article and then he can still change the
article so we're more in the core of
actually of the journalism so that's
that's cool so so this is actually what
we wanted to uh share about our model
are there
any questions first off hand of
applause